Birds of Prey gives viewers a pretty satisfying
and explosive ending But what we know about
the characters in their previous incarnations,
as well as the iconic Gotham City setting,
raises a ton of questions about what did and
didn' happen in the movie.
"Are we ready?"
Birds of Prey (And the Fantabulous Emancipation
of One Harley Quinn) begins with Harley breaking
the news that Joker has quite literally kicked
her to the curb, explaining the Clown Prince
of Crime's absence from the film.
Once word gets out that Harley is no longer
under Joker's protection, it spreads fast.
Roman Sionis, the crime boss known as Black
Mask, sends all of his men after her.
Plus, the cops and every thug who ever lived
through Harley's abuses are out to get their
pounds of flesh.
And Harley doesn't exactly go into hiding
she blows up Ace Chemicals in a breakup announcement
to the whole world.
It takes less than 24 hours for all of Gotham
to know that Harley Quinn just sprouted a
huge target on her head.
It stands to reason Joker must have heard
about it all, too.
In most likelihood he would know all about
the plant explosion, Sionis capturing Quinn,
the hunt for the Bertinelli diamond and Quinn's
dust-up with the cops.
Assuming he does know what's happening between
Harley and Black Mask, he probably sees it
as a win-win either Harley kills a potential
rival of Joker's, or Sionis cuts off one of
Joker's loose threads for him.
A reasonable enough explanation is that Joker
would likely be content to sit back and let
the carnage unfold, though it's still a bit
hard to believe he wouldn't get involved somehow.
That guy loves attention.
In the real world, with Ben Affleck setting
aside the role of Batman and the shaky status
of DCEU's shared narrative, it isn't a huge
surprise that the Dark Knight doesn't make
an appearance in Birds of Prey.
But in-universe, considering most of the film
takes place in Gotham City, you've got to
wonder exactly why he's absent.
"So let me get this straight.
You do it dressed like a bat.
Like, an actual bat."
"It's worked for 20 years in Gotham."
After making a huge mess by blowing up Ace
Chemicals, Harley assaults over a dozen cops
in the GCPD, lets a bunch of prisoners loose,
and has a violent tussle with armed bikers
in the evidence room, likely tainting every
piece of evidence in there.
There's a killer on the loose, Huntress, shooting
mobsters in the throat with a crossbow.
Eventually, the clash between Harley and Black
Mask erupts into a full-scale war in Amusement
Mile.
With all that chaos, Batman should have shown
up at some point during the events of Birds
of Prey, right?
If we had to whip up an explanation for his
absence, maybe he was working with the Justice
League outside Gotham, maybe on another planet
or in another dimension.
Otherwise, it seems like there's no way he'd
let all this criminal activity happen on his
watch.
By the end of the movie, Renee Montoya, Huntress,
and Black Canary have joined forces to become
a more permanent and comics-accurate version
of the Birds of Prey.
We see a quick shot of them fighting together,
and though they have new costumes, Montoya
isn't doing anything special to hide her identity.
It makes us wonder if she'll ever take on
the role she's assumed in the comics: The
Question.
In the DC Comics series 52, Renee Montoya
is recruited by the original Question, Vic
Sage, shortly after she quits the GCPD to
help fight a criminal organization called
Intergang.
Sage eventually succumbs to cancer, and Montoya
succeeds him as the Question.
She continues to use the name as well as the
faceless mask, even though Vic Sage is alive
and well once more in the comics.
If Montoya plans to keep beating up criminals
with the other Birds of Prey, it probably
wouldn't be a bad idea to wear some kind of
mask.
Otherwise, it won't be long before every crook
in Gotham knows her address and her old co-workers
at the GCPD make her life a lot tougher..
The thing everyone is after in Birds of Prey
is the Bertinelli Diamond, a special jewel
encoded with the information needed to access
the offshore accounts containing the fortune
of the slaughtered Bertinelli crime family.
As the Birds of Prey celebrate retrieving
it at a Mexican restaurant, Harley and Cassandra
Cain slip out the back door and abscond with
it.
Harley then explains that she pawned the diamond
and used the money to start a new business
with Cassandra.
Wait, she pawned it?
Considering what Black Mask is willing to
do to get the gem, you would think accessing
and using the data herself would bring Harley
and Cassandra a lot more money than they could
get from even the most generous jeweler.
Harley isn't exactly the most reliable narrator,
so it's more than possible that she's leaving
out some details here.
The account information somehow got back to
Huntress so she could reclaim her family's
fortune to fund the new team, at the very
least.
One of the more compelling characters in Birds
of Prey is Dinah Lance, also known as Black
Canary.
We meet her first as a singer in Sionis' club,
and eventually she's promoted to be his driver.
Shortly afterward, Renee Montoya comes calling,
and the detective brings up Lance's mother,
who apparently at one time assisted the Gotham
Police.
Montoya urges Lance to be more like her mother,
which prompts Lance to remind Montoya that
her mother was killed without any police there
to help her.
Montoya insists whatever happened to Lance's
mother wouldn't have happened on her watch.
We're never told exactly how Black Canary
gets her sonic scream powers, but the Montoya/Lance
exchange implies that perhaps Lance was born
with the abilities and that her mother had
them before her.
Perhaps her mother actually used the name
Black Canary before her death, and perhaps
she was a superhero.
The comics version of Black Canary notably
inherited the name from her crime-fighting
mother.
The origin of the comic book Black Canary
has been changed several times.
In some versions, her sonic powers are magical
in nature.
In others, they're the results of experiments.
Birds of Prey ends without us knowing exactly
where Lance's scream comes from.
During Harley's assault on the GCPD, Harley
notices a Wanted poster with Captain Boomerang's
mugshot and says, "Hey, I know that guy!"
She knows him because they helped save the
world together in 2016's Suicide Squad.
Choosing Boomerang as the wanted man is interesting
for a couple of reasons.
For one, while Joker springs Harley out of
Belle Reeve at the end of Suicide Squad, Boomerang's
still a prisoner.
So, if four years later he's a wanted man
in Gotham, either he's already been released,
or he escaped.
And Captain Boomerang's usual stomping ground
is Central City, which is why it's Ezra Miller's
Flash who nabs him in Suicide Squad.
So why's this poster up in Gotham?
One intriguing possibility is that Boomerang
wasn't released and didn't escape.
Perhaps he's still working for Amanda Waller's
Task Force X, his work for "The Wall" recently
brought him to Gotham, and the local authorities
weren't informed.
It wouldn't be the first time Waller kept
her team's work a secret.
In the mid-credits scene in Suicide Squad,
Amanda Waller tells Bruce Wayne,
"You look tired.
You should stop working nights."
...implying that she knows he's Batman.
If Waller has the kind of resources to unearth
that secret, then how could Harley Quinn's
actions in Birds of Prey possibly stay off
her radar?
Waller is not someone who likes it when her
pawns are taken away without her permission.
When Joker breaks Harley Quinn out of Belle
Reeve at the end of Suicide Squad, the breakout
would almost definitely be followed by a massive
attempt to get Quinn back.
It's likely she would eventually resort to
unleashing the rest of Task Force X to retrieve
her.
And, again, Harley doesn't exactly make herself
tough to find.
She walks around in broad daylight in Gotham
City, robbing grocery stores and crying over
lost breakfast sandwiches.
It seems likely if Waller wanted Harley back
in Belle Reeve, she'd be in Belle Reeve.
Maybe in the upcoming sequel The Suicide Squad
we'll learn exactly why Waller stays her hand.
One possibility?
Waller might naturally assume that with Joker
and Harley's bizarre relationship, having
Harley on Task Force X will always invite
Joker's attention.
Maybe between Suicide Squad and Birds of Prey,
she decided the risks weren't worth the rewards.
Roman Sionis and Victor Zsasz have a strange
relationship.
Zsasz is Roman's right-hand man, utterly loyal
to him in every way.
He also seems to love pushing Roman toward
his darker urges, almost daring him to kill
anyone who gets in his way.
While we never see any blatant romance between
the characters, there are a number of scenes
when they get very close.
Zsasz in particular expresses a simmering
passion for Sionis — though it isn't clear
if that passion is romantic or part of Zsasz's
obsession with Sionis' violence.
We never get a clear answer, and both are
dead before the credits roll, so it's likely
we never will.
There was a partial answer from the actors
themselves, though, in late January 2020.
Speaking with Variety, Ewan McGregor first
said the villains' relationship was "very
complicated" and then eventually it was "more
than likely" that they were lovers.
Those answers weren't enough for some fans,
who accused the actors of marketing the characters
as potentially being gay while failing to
solidly represent a romantic relationship
between two men on the screen.
By the end of the movie, Harley has run off
to start her own thing with Cassandra Cain,
leaving the Birds of Prey to fend for themselves.
So one has to wonder what the relationship
will be now between Harley and the women with
whom she formed a brief, but successful alliance,
if any.
On one hand, Harley more than proves in the
final battle against Sionis and his army of
goons that she can be a team player if she's
invested in the goal.
On the other hand, considering her career
trajectory, it seems pretty likely that if
Harley and the Birds of Prey ever cross paths
again, they won't be on the same side.
She may have genuinely enjoyed her time with
her new friends, but her alliance with them
is still largely one of circumstance and convenience.
Add to that her theft of Dinah's car and the
fact that Harley is now unquestionably contributing
to the delinquency of a minor, and it'd be
tough to blame the Birds of Prey if they choose
not to pull their punches next time they see
Harley.
Dinah and Helena seem to have put their criminal
pasts behind them by teaming with an ex-cop
with a clear sense of right and wrong.
Viewers who stuck around until the end of
the credits know there was no post-credits
scene in Birds of Prey, but there some brief
audio.
Harley tells us we deserve something for sticking
around for so long and promises to reveal
a secret.
She says, "Did you know Batman f–" and then
the audio cuts out.
We don't know for sure what "secret" Harley
was going to reveal, but it seems the most
likely candidate can be found in DC Universe's
Harley Quinn animated series.
The cartoon includes a lot of violence and
profanity you wouldn't expect in, say, the
'90s Batman: The Animated Series.
One recurring joke in the series, starting
as early as the series premiere, is Harley's
insistence that Batman does very inappropriate
things with bats.
"Why are you protecting a psychotic clown
who treats you like garbage?"
"Asks the guy who f---s bats."
"He doesn't do that!"
Considering the very noticeable "F" sound
Harley makes before her post-credits audio
cuts out, we're guessing if we heard the whole
thing it would echo her animated counterpart's
beliefs.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the DC
movie universe are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.